[Music]
gwl is back kinda and not here as of
today there's a brand new channel by
Wendover productions and it's called
half is interesting the videos are about
half as long and probably about half as
good as the ones here it's essentially
the continuation of the old twl series
without the restriction of only picking
topics from that Wikipedia list there's
no more waiting because the first video
is up now and it's about what's the
longest drivable distance on earth
videos will be going up there weekly
every Thursday at 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Wendover productions will remain just as
it always has the only difference is
that you can go listen to more and more
of this voice over there I'd really
appreciate it if you go over there and
subscribe to at least give it a try for
a few episodes I've been putting a lot
of work into developing that channel and
hopefully it will end up being something
great
[Music]